in this capsule we will see the concept
of generalization of the flu
learning then we saw different
learning apparatus commented this
that they are able to learn to
from data from the set
training now commented this
that we evaluate the success of the algorithm to
find us a model that will us
allow to make predictions that
are valid
intuitively the first thing to
which one could think of is
look at their ways but committed on
training examples
however this mistake there she goes
necessarily is optimistic why
but from a higher level we know that
our model h the model that makes them
predictions and had a very exciting
who was calculating hdx to make a
prediction of the target I'm going to have
actually hot already seen the right answer
on these examples
ok so in fact all we are in
front train and measure the capacity
of a gorith atom to find a model
who is able to memorize parker
what is the answer for them so the
target y for external examples to his
drive for example if we take the
coc case closer neighbors but
for that equals 1 to do on the room
drive his mistake is always going
to be zero because if I give him
an andrée xx that is in the
training room and well then if
all my entries are always good
labeled as a whole
training but necessarily because
that he memorized essentially
remember all the examples
drive he will be able to find
the one that fits my entry is ok
to be his closest neighbor for a
distance from zero with that there and goes
necessarily well predict his ethics
ok so the drive error is
really not a good measure for
know which point an algorithm
learning find a good model
since we can have an age
who makes good predictions made
what really interests us is the
ability of an algorithm to find a
model that will generalize about
new examples and finally sahara does
much better
the context in which we will use
people back learning little
model driven by an organ
learning so if I'm trying to
solve to render on data by
example a neural network that makes
of character recognition me
what interests me is to know
solve it further if I deploy it in
an application then he receives from
new new character images
who will be able to recognize these
new images there a new
Sunday and character and a risk
to be different anyway
exactly the same as those that the
world training set so that's
what's called the ability to
generalize to new examples and
to measure this ability to
generalization there what are we going to do in
practice is that we will put
examples enacted aside so they go
not to be in the whole
training and 6 example that I would have
put aside I will call them the
examples from my test set
I'm going to create a set that we're going to
call the test set that is going
contain examples that are not in
my training set that will be
not used to train my model
with my seasoned to take 7
so what is the relationship between
the drive error the error of
tests in practice actually for example if
we had several neural networks
with a number of neurons cachet
different
so we trained a network of neurons
they have with one layer hide and
5.9 in cash and in the 19th rank to hide
therefore 5.9 in cash and 10 9 in cash and 15.9
in cash and so killed ten years up to 109
in cash and that we can expect
level of the difference between the error
of classification that I'm going to measure this
moment in training and the one that I
am going to measure on my a no doubt is this
that I'm going to call the test error this
what we are going to observe is
firstly the training ro vote
mans horseback riding to be smaller than
the test error so the number
of errors that will make no my network
neurons regardless of the number of
hidden areas that I'm going to use on
the training area this number of
relay will always be smaller than
on the test set ok so here the
dotted curve is the error of
test for different by dunod
laurent to hide then the full curve
that's for the test set so
you were in the gym
lines full of teeth no doubt is this
just the first thing he always goes there
have a space so a difference
between workouts and and celeron
drive is always worth a lower
what the sco will also see is at
as we go up
number of neurons actually hide this
difference the antrum the two courses is going
to grow so as we
is going to have more neurons hide we're going
see the difference between the two
curves get bigger at the point that it goes there
possibly have a point where there in
made the mistake of tests going to start
increase because the rounds
drive she's always going down
their workout decreases because
our neural network for different
number of hiding neurons they are trying
to minimize this maple more I him
give nothing to hide anymore there is
memory are wants more is able to
memorize information before center
drive so more be able
to have a small child mistake
on the other hand, on the test error
will observe is that in fact the
performance on the stage error
drive is going to be less have
thought less and less the
performance on our set of tests
so why is it seen on
why are the breeds but
increase a bath it's a concept that
is a little difficult to grasp well a
costume this would be the case where I would have a
training set where there would be
some of the examples would be wrong
labeled so because my networks of
neurons for a different number
of neurons hide trying to memorize
information through training
but if I give a lot of neurons it
is going to need to memorize these errors
there and on mezin example in my
set of tests that may have been
well labeled for some examples
lodges
I would certainly have a general
what we are going to observe is that
if there are certain variations does
to memorize these variations
the other one in the whole workouts that
not going to bring my neural network to
to learn what is the reason
fundamental that makes that one by
example a character image
corresponds to two ways will put
then on trained on details
associated these examples that not allow
to generalize to examples of
test so what are we going to say in fact this is
that this number of neurons hidden here here
which is a bit the ideal ie
if I do not do it anymore I would have asked
my test error but if I had
does it less I will have a test error
worry because was bigger so if I
find me to the left of this point there we go
to say that I am below
learning not say that I could
increase the capacity of my model by
example to neural networks and then
improve my performance on my
set of tests
I find myself right on the e-v time on
learning ie we have
started learning from the parkers of
details that are overall
training and that does not put well
predict well performed on my old
nantais what made me me but the least
well performed on my set so for
a neural network at a different
in cash and that's what we're going
observe more have neurons cachet
the more I will be able to optimize my
drive error possibly I
will reach a point where I'm going
pass under learning ensures
learning where I'm going but will put
less well performed at risk my
performance on my test set on
could say the same thing but on the
number of iterations of a network of
hikes with a fixed man from
neurons hide so if I take my
optimization algorithm by december
stochastic gaza we want to measure
that I'm going to train a currency makes
your minuee necessarily because
that's what I'm trying to optimize by
against it will happen a number
of iterations there I'm actually going to
take particularities my old
drive that will not allow me
to generalize on my agenda
tests but which in the reverse
empire and my performances on my
examples that are different that are
in all of all and so
general so sure my axis dxy if I
put any parameter option
from my grandmother's apprenticeship who
gives more ability to memorize this
that in the training set this
that I observed these two curves it is
to say a curve for ranks
training that constantly sees
decreased but for the test dresses so
my generalization performance that is going
decrease but eventually who will
put to increase and so if I have a
regret is that 4 of the options that allows
to control the ability of my model to
memorize the data what I would like
it is to find this point which is the
point where I have the best compromise
between soft or learning and on
learning that is found at
to be there points that separate diets
source or learning and on
learning
ok so those options there that I'm talking about
and that allows me to control the
ability to memorize on my set
training
if what we will call hypers
so allow the options but
for the nearest neighbors eco label
that would be the case value for the
hut of the collector to swells algre
logistic regression
I have to if I want to run it determine
what is the alpha learning rate
what is the number of iterations
also for a neural network that
would it be the rate
iphone learning the number
iterations but also the number of
neurons hide the number of layers
hide or if the choice of the function
activation we saw only the
sigmoid but overall it's
possible of this high function so
all these are options that I have
specified hamon has little learning
so that I can execute it and its
options there we will call them zips
apparently so it's for the
distinguish parameters from a model
as
a neural network that would have said that
weights that the weight of
connections between neurons worry
parameters that are adjusted by
pride learning the parameters
and option plans that are not
adjusted by learning flu
we must specify aprilia so
comment what his settings choose
there to avoid doing the over
learning then or doing sudan
learning to have the best
compromise on the good learning da
I can not choose from the eren
drive choose camera option
soaping
necessarily hard learning
so we have seen for example the number
Iterations more I have but more my
training ground your base so
I would simply choose number
of iterations that is bigger than them
but I could actually so it's going
bring necessarily hard learning
a point where they eventually want
the test rom will increase today
only to the nearest neighbors if
I used the training role
since klm gives an error of 0
I will always use cepoun
oath what is the best for good
generalize it would be very tempting
to use my set of tests that
I set aside to measure the
generalization ability but that and
it's very important it would be cheating
these examples of tesco it really has to
represent examples that I
do not know yet and who
would face my system
when they would be deployed so I
should not use it nor could
coach nor to choose my options if
no actually I could choose
so in fact choose my examples me the
value of the hyper parameters based
of the set of tests so kind of like
driven these options the seizure is not going
put the food on my set of
tests
so that would be it would give me a
optimistic measure of my ability to
generalize
so in fact what are we going to do a little
as for the tabs test set
different examples of the room
drive the shadow of the examples are
different sets of test and
the coach set so we're going to have
another set
put aside we will call it
the hockey validation set and so
it will allow us not to use
the test set for because I
want to keep it without using it I'm going
use it only the very end for
measure the validation performance that
lets me not use the whole
drive also they
would necessarily lead to hard
learning
so my validation set that's
only goal is going to be to determine the
father values ​​parameters and a destiny
different by the way had to do settings
on and evaluating it on performance
on the validation set in fact one
can see some form
learning we will adapt my game
our owl various settings but
on the validation data rather than
the input data ok so here we have the
description of an evaluation procedure
complete on a set despite
learning and wishes to evaluate at
what a point this tiger and allows them to
to get the model that perform well
sure of new outfits what are we going
to do is we will take all our
data we collected we want them
divide into three sets my whole
workout my set of
validation and my set of tests
an example of separation this would be
take seventy for that of
examples for training 15% for the
15% validation for the test
so we could have chosen other
percentage it's an example that I
I often use practices then who
walk pretty well
and so I have all my examples but I
must you also me example I'm going
represents by this rectangle
I could take 70% for
15% training for validation
then 15% for the test then and that's
what I'm going to do is a list of
all the values ​​said not to promise
that I should try so if I want
lead a
the flu of a model with the algorithm
the taxman
I could be choosing the rate
learning for example 0.1 then to
try to say 100 iteration where I
may take 0.01 pieces and also for
santhera sion I could try
other fathers different settings
like that where I can vary also the
number of iterations for a network of
neurons it could be the so let's say
I have a training criterion that
allows to specify my number
of iterations ben that might be the
learning rate and the number of
neurons hide so like that I do
a list of all the values
possible configurations possible
great settings I make a list
that I wish to evaluate the choice of
validated alas for each element of
this list there i will run my
learning pride about my old
drive then once the place
learning
once he has finished his execution
I will evaluate the performance of the model
driven on the validation set
so for each of the father's choices
settings i will keep in memory
what are the performance maybe
that if I had 10% errors on
my validation set maybe here
I would have said 5% the ranks the
giants figures like that but for
all but my father's configuration
allow I'll put aside the
measuring the performance on my old
validation and finally the end
what I'm going to do is I'm going
succeed executed my opinion and
learning but only for
hypers allow with the best
performance in validation
so in this case if it had been submitted
but resumes but because I know that
manage would run my art algorithms
showing off parameter there and that's the model
resulting from these learnings there that
I will use to evaluate the performance
on my set of tests
so I say run them what I
could do is keep in memory
also all models
if I did a taxman so have here
I reindeer worth my father mw that I
could put in memory in addition to his
performance I could take these
super allow them to put the value of
w parameter
with w in memory in addition to the
performance is rather re executed
the algorithm I just think I use my
model that I would have saved on 10
but often practicing doing so we
is certainly of the temperament
not want to keep all the parameters but
me it would be too much it would take too much
dead so often we performed well
holger note of learning but there with
the iron mayors allow one to have
found and one evaluates the model
results on the test set times
and that measure on all of
all and for all purposes it's going to be our
estimate that will not be optimistic so
we're going to say formally that it's a
unbiased estimate of performance
of generalization of my home so if
this procedure there that will allow me
to evaluate the capacity of an algorithm
learning allow to do well
perform in generalization and I
could use but you have this
procedure there to compare different
learning algorithms if I
wanted calculation compared to that range
super scepter meyers for this problem there
that the 2-2 algorithm for
the training of wall networks have
compared with a co nearest neighbors
but I will repeat this procedure
individually for the collector have
for the nearest neighbors case and for
the neural network and then I could
compare at that moment the performance
between metro learning algorithms
to have an unbiased measure of
kehl and the algorithm that has the best
performance for my problem so that's
like that we have to use
this is the standard procedure for evaluating
the performance of a shed
learning